اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه اخباريه مفصله
من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
رغم الهدنه لاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تتجدد في محيط القص الجمهوري في
الخرطوم
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يؤكد في تصريحات
للعربيه ان كل مستشفيات غرب دارفور خرجت
عن الخدمه
ووصل تحذيرات من تفاقم الاوضاع مبعث الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه يصل الى السودان
ايضا
روسيا تعلن تفكيك الشبكه الاوكرانيه تقول
انها خططت في تنفيذ اعمال ارهابيه
وتخريبيه في القرن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا التغطيه مستمره لتطورات
القتال بين طرفي الصراع في السودان الجيش
والدعم السريع اشتباكات تدخل يومها التاسع
عشر على التوالي من دون افق لحل وشيك
طيران الجيش يحلق في سماء العاصمه ويتقدم
في محيط القصر الجمهوري والدعم السريع يرد
بالمضادات الارضيه رغم تبادل الاتهامات
بين الجنرال الجنرالين البرهان وحميتي
بخرق هدل سابقه تتزايد دعوته لهدنه مطوله
فهل تلقى مصير سابقتها وعلى وقع تمدد
المعارك والتفلت الامني وقطاع الصحه
والقطاع الصحي على وشك الانهيار تتعادل
تحذيرات الامميه من تفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه ياتي ذلك فيما وصل مبعوث الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه الى السودان في
مهمه عاجله بينما تتواصل عمليات النزوح
واللجوء بالالاف
من يوم الارض من الخرطوم فكان المعساه
يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد احنا 28
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم تاشيره وخليناه
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت اللذانات
من تحت الدرب وطناري من يعني
لحد ما حصلنا
طلعت من البيت كان تقريبا الساعه عشره
طلعت ما فيش ولا ركشه ولا مواصله وسيارات
بس بتعدي فش حدا بيوقف لك وكان ورا البيت
فيه زي في المنطقه الصناعيه محروقه فكان
لسه الدخان شغال فيعني عنجد حسيت انه يعني
رعب هو كان في شعور يعني خوف
ورعب يعني انك تشوف جوتك مرميه يمين يسار
وناس مقطعه
والبنوك محروقه يعني بتحسي انه خلاص في
امان نهائي ومستقبل الوقف
[موسيقى]
افادت مصاديو العربيه بان الجيش السودانيه
يحاول التقدم نحو القصف الجمهوري والدعم
يتصدى بمضادات الطيران في الاثناء افاد
مراسله العربيه بتجدد الاشتباكات رغم
الهدنه السادس المعلنه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع واضاف المراسله ندويا انفجارات سمع
في الخرطوم واندرمان ورصد المراسل تحليقا
لطائرات الجيش السوداني في سماء العاصمه
حيث استهدفت تمركزات تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع وفي المقابل ردت قوه الدعم السريع
بمضادات ارضيه في محيط القصر الرئاسي
هذا هو نشر الجيش الصور لضبط مخازن اسلحه
قال انها تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع حيث
تحتوي الاف الذخائر
مخازن
مخازن تحت الدول معسكر تحت الدول
للتاريخين
تحت الدول مخازن الارضيه تحت الجبل
مخزن عملاق مخزن كبير جدا جدا
في الاثناء لا تزال الاتهامات متبادله
بشان خرق الهدن المعلنه منذ بدء الصراع في
اخرها بيان للجيش حمل قوات الدعم السريع
المسؤوليه عن خرق الهدنه في الاحياء
السكنيه البيان اشار الى وقوع اعمال نهب
للبنوك والمحلات التجاريه في المحيط استاد
الهلال بامدرمان لافتا الى هروب اعداد
كبيره من قوه الدعم السريع من ام درمان
باتجاه الغرب وقال الجيش ان السفير الهند
في الخرطوم ابلغ عن اقتحام السفاره وسرقه
ممتلكاتها
رغم اعلان جنوب السودان موافقه اطراف
الصراع في السودان على وقف اطلاق النار
لمده اسبوع اعتبار من يوم غد الخميس قال
يوسف عزت مستشار حلمته العربيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع لم توافق بعد على الهدنه كما
اكد انهم لا يرفضون الهدى في حال ضمان
الالتزام بها متهما الجيش السودانيه
بخرقها
لم يستطع البرهان
وما زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش هدنه معلنه
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويخطف مواقعنا
لم يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن فمن نستغرق
لاوانه
لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد نهايه هذه الهدنه نحن
نتعامل مع قوه
وافقنا على هدى بواسطه امريكا بواسطه
السعوديه لم يتم الالتزام على بالهدنه ليس
لدينا مانع شهود جديده لكن لابد ان تكون
هنالك جهه ما تقول من خلق الهدنه
دعا عدد من المواطنين بجنوب دارفور طرفي
النزاع في السودان الى ضروره وقف الحرب
والاقتتال مشيرين الى ان الصراع خلف اثارا
اقتصاديه كبيره منها
ركود السلعي وارتفاع الاسعار
والله يا اخي نتمنى من الحكومه يعني
يتوافقوا ويتفقوا
يتعاونوا واحنا كلنا سودانيين مع اننا فرق
بين الاحمر اصفر اخضر
جيش ابناء
الدعم السريع يا ابنائنا ما في حاجه داخل
السكر
في امان في الاحياء
لما نرجع للعلاج الليله العلاج
انتم بتغيروا في نفسكم انتم سكر من 30 يا
جماعه الى 80 والزيت من من خمسه الى 35
دقيقه بيزيد كل المواطنين يا جماعه ان
السوق دائما بكره وبعد بكره وقدام البنوك
هتفتح واي زول يا جماعه يجي يفتح دكانه
وما يتخوفوا نسال الله ان يوحدنا سبحانه
وتعالى اولا الوحده كل الناس يعني تتوحد
عشان تصل لبره الامان باذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى
هدى متتاليه في السودان كلها بائت بالفشل
ولم تحقق الاهداف المرجوه سواء بالتواصل
لوقف دائم لاعمال العنف او فتح ممرات
انسانيه لموسعه اهالي في السودان ليتم
خرقها باستمرار بواسطه بهذه الاتهامات
بالخرق بين طرفي النزاع
مقترح هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود
بالالتزام ومن ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو
متطابق تكرر 6 مرات على مدار اسبوعين في
السودان دائما ما ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها
دون اي نتائج مرجوه مع تبادل طرفي الصراع
الاتهامات بخرقها
الى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تم تعب ببساطه امريكيه لكن
الانفجارات والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليقا لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من قوه
الدعم السريع
خروق كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى اندرمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
هدن لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا
لفتح باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد
ولم تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم
المترديه وعمر العربيه
في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام حد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله مرورا بابو
ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما نظمت
الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع الشهيد
ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق الشعبي
بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق الحيويه اما
حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق امتداد شارع
الرميله مرورا بصك العمله ومخازن السكر
والمنطقه الصناعيه الحملات حققت اهدافها
المطلوبه بمشاركه الق وات المسلحه لتامين
الاسواق والمناطق التجاريه الهامه
والمرافق الحيويه
نخلط مشاهدينا خرطوم بحري ينضم الينا
الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان محمد معنا في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه بدايه ما حقيقه الاوضاع
الامنيه والميدانيه وانسانيه ايضا في
مدينه بحري
نعم مرحبا احمد لا زالت الطائرات تحلق في
سبا الخرطوم في هذه اللحظات
انتقل مسرح العمليات بالكامل ربما الى
منطقه شرق النيل هذه المره وقبل ذلك علمنا
من بعض المصادر بان هناك اشتباكات عنيفه
دارت ما بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه كافوري هذه الاشتباكات اسفلت عن ان
الجيش
بمداهمه بعض المنازل في منطقه كافوري هذه
المنازل بحسب المصادر يختبئ فيها عدد من
قوات البيع ويديرون من خلالها عمليات هي
منازل قيل بانها
النافذين او بعض الضباط الذين كانوا
يستقلونها تابعونا
[موسيقى]
الدعم السريع كذلك الاحظ احمد بان سحب
الدخن واضحه بانها من معسكر المظلات
يشهد قصف عنيف منذ ليله الامس
هذا واحد من المعسكرات الكبيره كما تعلم
بالقرب من جسر الشمبا الان ترتفع من هناك
سحب الدخان الكفيف مما يدل على ان هذه
الطائرات قامت بعمليات قصف قبل قليل مره
اخرى لهذا المعسكر كذلك ترتفع صحوب الدخان
قربي اندرمان
ايضا بان هناك بعض القصف تم لمنطقه جسر
ودى البشير بان عدد من القوات كانت تتمركز
في هذه المنطقه احمد
طيب محمد ايضا بحسم مشاهداتك يعني لمن
تبدو يعني في صالح متى تبدو السيطره
للميدانيه او السيطره في التمركزات لدعم
الجيش في شوارع بحر تحديدا
واضح احمد بان الجيش بدا يسيطر على الموقف
من خلال هذا التقدم الواسع على ارض
العمليات قلنا في بادي الامر اذا ما حلقت
هذه الطائرات نستمع سريعا الى صوت
المضادات الارضيه وهي ترد وتبادل هذه
الطائرات القصف ولكن الان
اشاهد هذه الطائرات الان في هذه اللحظات
تحلق هذه الطائرات في سماء الخرطوم بحري
المنطقه التي انا متواجد فيها ولا اسمع
لاصوات لمضادات طائرات الا من الحيله او
من الحيله والاخرى هذه دلاله وافيه على
انه كما تحدث الجيش ربما تم اضعاف هذه
القوات بنسب عاليه تجاوزت الخمسين بالمئه
طيب بحسب بيان لقوات الدعم السريع يوم امس
اعلنت فيه ان الجيش السوداني قصف
بالطائرات مستشفى شرق النيل هل من تاكيد
لهذه المعلومه او نفي لها
هذه المعلومه حاولنا بالاتصال بعدد من
المصادر ولكن هذه المنطقه وجود الدعم
السريع حولها كثيف احمد لذلك يصعد ربما
على بعض المصادر الوصول الى هذا المستشفى
الذي تبدو فيه الامور غامضه منذ فترات
طويله لتواجد هذه القوات بكثافه في هذه
المنطقه ولكن حدثتنا مصادر غير رسميه
حدث لي انه تم القصف على جانب هذه
المستشفى ولم تتاثر المستشفى بصوره رسميه
هذه مصادميه بقيه مستشفيات بحري مسيغه
الرئيسيه الى اي مدى هي قادره على تقديم
خدمتها في هذا الوضع
نعم كما هو معلومه معظم المستشفيات خرجت
عن الخدمه تمام المستشفى بحري
تعاني الاشكاليات هنا مستشفى واحد هو الذي
يعمل مستشفى او المستشفى الدولي انا اتحدث
عن المستشفيات الرسميه المستشفى الدولي
قائد الان هو الذي يعمل بينما مستشفى
البراحه تم اغلاقه منذ الغصه الذي تم
السوق المركزي البحري وشنبات الاخر خرج عن
الخدمه مستشفى بحري كذلك خارج الخدمه لا
يعمل سوى المستشفى الدولي الان في في بحري
وهذا يمثل واحده من الاشكاليات الكبيره
احمد على الضغط الذي يحدث لنا لكن الاحظ
طبعا في المناطق التي هي شمال الجزيره
الحلفايه هذه الاحياء الان ايضا فيها هدوء
واستقرار واضح حركه الناس هنا في الشوارع
الاسواق الان مفتوحه بعض المحال مفتوحه
هنا تبدو شبه طبيعيه في شمال بحري
بالتحديد
طيب محمد تفضل بالبقاء معي ساعود اليكم
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره ايضا من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم على وقع الهجمات
والمواجهات المتبادله بين قوات الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ونشاهد ايضا
في هذه الصور مشاهدينا اعمده الدخان التي
تتصاعد من بعض المناطق في العاصمه الخرطوم
نذكر مشاهدينا بان هذه المواجهات
والاشتباكات دخلت يومها التاسعه عشر على
التوالي دون افق لحل وشيك
وكذلك طيران الجيش يحلق يسمى العاصمه
والدعم السريع يرد على هذه الغارات التي
ينفذها الطيران الجيش السوداني بالمضادات
الارضيه وهناك ايضا تبادل للاتهامات
مشاهدينا بين الجنرلين البرهان وحميتي
بخرق الهدى السابقه وهناك ايضا دعوات
لهدنه مطوله ربما تصل لاسبوع اعلن حتى
الان مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان حميدتي اعلن يوسف عزه ان الدعم
السريع لم يوافق حتى الان على هذه الهدنه
المطوله حتى اللحظه
مشاهدينا ينضم الى المحلل العسكري الفريق
الرحمن محي الدين اهلا بك سعاده الفريق
معنا بدايه ما هي قراءتك الى الوضع
الميداني للطرفين بعد ان وصلت المواجهات
ليومها التاسع عشر
سيطرتها بشكل واسع جدا على كل انحاء
العاصمه تقريبا وهنالك انتشار واسع جدا
للقوات المسلحه لتطهير المناطق التي تتحسن
فيها عناصر الدعم السريع القوات المسلحه
يعني تعمل بالحد الادنى من القوه حتى الان
لتجنيب المدنيين مزيدا من الخسائر لكن
للاسف يعني عناصر الدعم السريع الان احتلت
مستشفيات احتلالا كاملا وحولتها الى سوق
النادي العسكريه
طبعا يعني حريص جدا ان لا تتعرض لهذه
المستشفيات لانهم في بعض المستشفيات
يحتجزون اطباء كارهين
ويقدرونهم على معالجه جرحاهم في هذه
المستشفيات والتي تحولوها الى عسكريه
وضعوا الارتداد على اصلها العلويه
وابخلوا سياراتهم باعداد كبيره داخل هذه
المستشفيات وهذا وضع يعني مثري جدا ولكن
للاسف
نقابه الاطباء ان تتحدث عن هذا الموضوع
الذي يمسدهم مباشره كنقابه واجبه حمايه
حقوق الاطباء الا انها تتحدث عن ان هنالك
جرحى وهنالك ابرياء وحديث ممزوج لا قيمه
له بدلا تحدث عن
الشان الذي يعنيهم اصلا هنالك اصفاء
مختطفون هنالك اطباء قتلوا هنالك اطباء
يقدرون على يبقوا كراهين داخل هذه
المستشفيات ولكن للاسف هذه النقابه يعني
ظلت تتحدث حديث
عموما نقول ان الوضع تحت السيطره المسلحه
بشكل كبير
وسيع المسلحه الى التحرير هؤلاء الرحايل
بيتكلم ويمكن
تسعى الى تحرير الرهائي لكن ما داعي الهدف
الاسماء الجيش السوداني سنه الفريق في هذه
المرحله يعني هل نتحدث عن ازاحه الدعم
السريع من مشهد تماما هنتحدث عن اخراجه من
العاصمه فقط ام اعتقال قيادته او قتلهم ما
الذي يخطط له الجيش تحديدا وما الذي ينوي
فعله
منذ اليوم الاول كانت خطه القوات المسلحه
واضحه المسلحه تعمل على القضاء على هذا
التمرد والجزازه تماما صحيح هنالك عفو عام
صدر من الاقوات المسلحه
لعناصر الدعم السريعه في هذه المعركه
مرتاح لهم الفرصه حتى الان كل من يضع
سلاحه يمكن ان يتم دمجه داخل المسلحه او
يتم تسريحه حسب رغبته لكن بهذه التمرد له
مجال للتفاوض معها ولا بد من اكتشافها
تماما يعني اكد بالامس عضو مجلس السياده
يقول الفريق اول ياسر
عبد الرحيم محمد حمدان دقله
اصبح له مجالا لهم لا في العمل السياسي
ولا في العمل العسكري بالمره في السودان
وبالتالي الخياراتهم ثلاثه اما ان
يستسلموا ويقدموا الى محاكمات واما ان
يهربوا ينزل عنهم الفرصه للهرب
ولكن رغم ذلك سعاده الفريق يعني السيد
حميد مع حفظ الالقاب ما زال نائبه للبرهان
حتى اللحظه في مجلس السياده ولم يتم اعفاه
حتى الان لماذا في تقديرك
هذا تحصيل حاصل واتخذ هذا الموقع بناء على
انه غايه القوات الدعم السريع الدعم
السريع تم حلها بغرار من رئيس مجلس
السياده والاعتبارها قوه متمرده وبالتالي
يعني اصبح له جودا لحمايه لا في المجلس
عسكريه وكذلك لشقيقه هذه الرتب يعني
تحصلوا عليها وهذه نقلوها بحكم قيادتهم
للدعم السريع الذي تم حله وبالتالي قيمه
لا يكونوا لا زالوا
عن كونهم قادر للدعم وانما حديث عن كونه
اتحدث وتحديدا محمد حمدان هو نائب البرهان
في مجلس السياده
من اين اتى بهذه الوظيفه اصلا من اين اتى
بعذبه لمجلس السياده اتى بها لقيادته
الدعم السريعه التي كانت شريكات المسلحه
لكن عندما تمردت وتم حلها اذا لا وجود له
في مجلس القياده بالتاكيد
هل سيوافق الجيش السوداني في مرحله ما على
التفاوض
مع غياده التمرد نعم
هذا امر مستحيل لا يمكن لا القوات المسلحه
ولا الشع
ب السوداني بعد كل هذا الدمار وكل هذه
الخسائر يعقل ان نعود مره اخرى ويجلس
قيادات من القوات المسلحه مع قياده التمر
ولكن هناك انباء ايضا متداوله في وكالات
الانباء عن
تسميه الجيش السودانيه ممثلين له في
مفاوضات مقبله مع الدعم السريع في احدى
الدول الاقليميه
بالتحديد بناء على المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه وهذا التفاوض ياتي في اطار تحسين
الوضع الانساني لانه الحزن الانتهاء التي
عقدت كلها نفذت كلها لم تفيد المواطن لذلك
اخيرا لانه العناصر الدعم الشريحه تحتل
محطات الكهرباء وتحتل محطات المياه خاصه
في منطقه بحري التي تعاني من انقطاع
المياه لايام طويله هذا بسبب وجودهم داخل
هذا المحطات اذن المواطن لا يستفيد من
الهدنه الغرض من التفاوض هذا اخراج عن
ناصر الدعم السريع من المرافق الخدميه هذه
ومن الاحياء السكنيه التي يكبلون بها
المواطنين
حتى الظروف المواطن ومعيشه المواطن عندما
تعلن يجد فعلا ان هناك
يحسن الموضوع المعيشي فيها وتتوصل له
الخدمات فيها هذا الغرض ولكن ليس التفاوض
لاحياء الدعم السريع من جديد موضوع الدعم
السريع كما ذكرت لك في هذا التمرد
خياراتها ثلاثه ذكرتها اما بقيت عناصر
الدعم السريفه وسلمت اسلحتها وارحب بها
القوات المسلحه يمكن ان يتم دمجها
وتسريحها حسب ما تقتضيه
طيب قوات الاحتياط المركزي ايضا سعاده
الفريق التابع للشرطه هل هي منخرطه في
القتال الدائري الى جانب الجيش
الاحتياطي المركزي ليس الدعم السريع
القوات الاحداث المركزي تم انزالها الى
المناطق التي تم تطهيرها من التمرد لكي
تفرض هيبه الدوله ولكي تؤمن المواطنين من
المجرمين الذين تم اطلاق سراح
هم سجون خلال الاسبوع الماضي هنالك من 12
الى 13 الف من المحتدل خرج من السجون ولا
بد من تامين المواطنين من ترويح هؤلاء
المجرمين فكان هذا واجب الاحتياطي المركزي
ولقد
تابعتم وقبل
بمصدر في صدر هذه النشره انها الدعم
السريع عفوا عناصر الاحتياطي المركزي
تمكنت من تطهير
الاس من المجرمين ومن تطهير المناطق في
الخط الجنوبي
لمحافظه من منطقه
القريبه من جبل اوليا وارتداد الشمال الى
ان وصلت الى المنطقه الصناعيه الخرطوم هذا
يؤكد ان هنالك سيطره واسعه للقوات الشرطه
في المناطق التي تم تطهيرها من التمرد
وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان الاحساس المركز
الان يطلع بدوره الاصل مراده وتامين
المواطنين من المجرمين ولقد تمكن من
احتجاز يعني
عشرات المئات من
المجرمين في هذه المنطقه خلال ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه شكرا لك من الخرطوم كنت مع المحلي
العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين
تحياتي
مشاهدينا وفي تداعيات المواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السيرافي دهر فور اظهرت الصور
احتراق اكبر سوق للبقوليات في نيالا عاصمه
جنوب دارفور حيث سقطت قذائف متبادله من
طرفي الصراع ما تسبب في خسائر كبيره في
الاسواق التجاريه في الاقليم
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من الخرطوم المحل
السياسي عمار العركي اهلا بك سيدي عمار
معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه بدايه ما هي
قراءتك الوضع السوداني حاليا وفي اي سنه
ما هي اكثر سيناريوهات ترجيحا تحدث في
الفتره المقبله
القائمه من خلال
الثلاثه يوم الماضيه وحسب القراءه على
الارض
بان خطه الجيش المعلنه من اول يوم تمضي
تمضي
بنجاحاته وان كانت بطيئه حسب ما اعلن
الجيش
يراعي للمدنيين ورائي التحتيه وبالمقابل
نجد هنالك هنالك عدم ثباته او هنالك
خطه دعم الدعم السريع
واستكون يعني تؤثر بخلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين
بالاستنزاف او بالحصار او بضرب الامداد
نلاحظ حتى الهدنه الاخيره الاقتراع لم يكن
لم يكن بالحجم الذي سبق الهدنه التي قبلها
مما يدل على ان الان
قوات الدعم السريع تضررت كثيرا على مستوى
الاعداد
والافرادات الان بعد ان كانت في الاسابيع
الاولى كانت مبادره وتهاجم وتسيطر
وحتى تطورت الى منطقه جبل اوليا وهاجمت
القائد الجويه هنالك مواصفات الجيلي ولكن
الان خلال الهدنه الاخيره تتمركز في
مواقعها وفي خط الدفاع وحتى دفاعاتها كما
ذكر مراسلكم قبل قليل الان لا ترد على
الطائرات بصوره كنا نلحظها
من جنوب الخرطوم حتى شمال الخرطوم لكل
المضادات تعمل في وقت متزامن ولكن حتى هذه
الظاهره يعني ثلاثه مما يدل بان بان
القوات الدعم السريع الان حسب ما ذكر
ياسر ياسر العطاء في نهاياته او في بدايات
لانهيار التام
طيب غياب الالتزام او عدم الالتزام بهذه
الهدن حتى اللحظه يعني في تقديرك هل يعود
الى غياب اراده حقيقيه لدى الطرفين اما
الغياب العناصر والشروط الضامنه لتطبيقها
على الارض
[موسيقى]
كان يرفض مبدا الهدنه والتفاوض او الحوار
ولكن حسب ما اعلن تقدير للظروف الانسانيه
قبل بالهدنه
القوات الدعم السريع الان هي تذهب الى
اليهود حتى استلملم اطرافها وتعيد تموضعها
وتنتقد انقاصها ليس هنالك توجه حقيقي او
مصداقيه في الهدنه على الارض فتح المسارات
وتقديم العوامل الانساني للمتضررين الى
ذلك بان بان الخيار الذي يعني
التوحدت عليه جامعه الدول العربيه ومجلس
الامن والاتحاد الافريقي
بيتعدم التدخل عدم التدخل على الارض او
التدخل في الشان هذا الامر الابواب امام
اي اي مهود على الارض ان كان اجراءه فهو
تدق له مراقبه
فبالتالي نجد ان الهدنه تقدم من باب
الدعوات والرجاءات والطلبات وليس هنالك اي
يعني
دخول ممارسه او يلزام احد الاطراف بالقبول
والالتزام بها هل هناك نقطه فاصله او
مرحله معينه يمكن حين عن الطرفين الاقتناع
بعدم واقعيه استمرار هذه المعارك واللجوء
الى المقاربه الحسم العسكري
وطبعا
الطرفين المتفقان في هذا المبدا ان الفريق
البرهان منذ بدايه تحدد بان اي معركه لا
بد لها ان تنتهي بتفاوض وحواء وكذلك
حماسيه يتحدث بان هذه المعركه المنتصره
فيها المنتظر فيها خاطر وبالتالي هنالك
تكتيكات او مرحله كل طرف
جوده الوصول اليها ثم بعد ذلك سوف نلتقم
في نقطه نقطه الحوار والدروس التفاوض
الجيش سوف يعمل على اجزام حسب المخطط على
اجزام او طهر قوات الدعم الثري يا اما
يدفعها الى الاستسلام او للهروب
الان سوف بعدما تنهار الهدن وتبغض الفرصه
الفرصه
سوف تضطر الى احدى الخيارات التي فرضها
الجيش ولان هذا يحكمه الواقع ويحكمه العمل
على الارض فاما الاستسلام واما
القروب الان
شكرا لك يا الخرطوم كنت معنا المحلل
السياسي عمار العربي تحياتي
الجريمه دي فيها 85 دكان شاغل
مع ذلك مع الناس الضيوف معانا الضيوف برضو
يغدر بحوالي كم واربعين نفر دي كلها عندهم
فضائح حرقت في هذه المحل والله
200 جوال عدسيه كذا
ما شاء الله
وفي متابعه الاوضاع الطبيه كشف سكرتيرونا
قامت اطباء السودان عطيه عبد الله عطيه
للعربي عن وجود اكثر من 12 الف مريض
معرضون للموت بسبب الاوضاع الصحيه مشددا
على ضروره فتح ممرات امنه لايصال المعونات
الطبي غير المتضررين
الاعداد في ازدياده شديد وهي متواليه
متوقعه بعد يعني تزايد العسكريه سوف يكون
هنالك اكثر من 12 الف مريض معرض للموت
الان نحن لدينا تقارير من ان هنالك عدد من
المرضى توفي داخل منازلهم
المياه في المستشفيات وفي المنازل يشكل
مشكله كبيره جدا في ظل عدم وصول هذه
المعينات سوف يتعرض 12,000 للموت نحن
قلناها وكررناها ان طرفي الصراع في
السودان تركوا الشعب السوداني امام خيارين
اما الموت بالرصاص او الموت بالمرض حلو
البسيطه فقط فتح ممرات امنه بالتاكيد سوف
نصل الى هذه المستشفيات سوف يستطيع
الداعمين الوصول وتوصيل معاناتهم بالتاكيد
سوف يعني يتكاثف الجميع في في هذه الازمه
هكذا مدير جمعيه الاحمر السوداني في غرب
دارفور ابو بكر محمد الشريف لقناه العربيه
على ان كل المستشفيات غرب خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني واستمرار الحرب
التي ادت تضرر كل البناء التحتيه الصحيه
ولايه خرب تعرضت لكارسه كبيره جدا جدا ادى
الى تدمير كامل البنيه التحتيه للمؤسسات
بالاضافه لنظام الصحي بتاعه الولايه بشكل
كامل الان كل المستشفيات خارج الخدمه هذا
المستشفيات
ضعيفه جدا جدا فقط في الخيارات بتاعه
الخدمات بتاعت الاسعافات كل المخازن
الموجوده ثم نهبها تماما ما في اي خدمات
موجوده بتاعه الخدمات الصحيه تماما الهلال
الاحمر منذ
خمس ايام بدانا بنخذ
من مناطق مختلفه قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره
الصحه السودانيه تسجيل ست اصابات جديده
بولايه الخرطوم وحاله وفاه واحده بولايه
وسط دارفور ليقترب بذلك عدد الاصابات
التراكمي من 5000 اصابه وخمسمائه وخمسين
حاله وفاه في جميع انحاء البلاد واوضح
التقرير ان الهدوء يسود كافه الولايات
تعدى ورايته الخرطوم ووسط دارفور لكن
الجهات الطبيه تواصل تسجيل اصابات ووفيات
نتيجه الحرب القائمه
وفي محاوله لتخفيف اعباء القتال الداخلي
بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الذي يدور
في السودان منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يخاطر
مستشفى خاص في ام درمان بفتح ابوابه لخدمه
النساء الحوامل واجراء ولاده دون مقابل
مادي وفي ظل ظروف امنيه وانسانيه توصف
بالكارثيه
يرافق استمرار القتال في السودان
لكن مستشفى خاصا في ام درمان
ينجح بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء الحوامل
مجانا
في ظل نادى من شبه كامل للامن
وارتفاع اثمان المستلزمات في السوق
السوداء
اكثر من عشره اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
320 عمليه ولاده قيصريه اجراها منذ اندلاع
القتال
فيما تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان
اكثر من خمسين مستشفى بالخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل
وتحذيراته من انهيار القطع الصحي تتواصل
هو في تداعيات القتال المستمر في السودان
اعلنت الامم المتحده ان اسعار السلع
الاساسيه من الوقود الى المواد الغذائيه
والمياه المعبئه ارتفعت بنسبه 40 الى 60%
او اكثر في بعض المناطق وافاد برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي بان نحو ثلث سكان البالغ
عددهم اكثر من سته واربعين مليون شخص
كانوا يعانون من الجوع قبل اندلاع الصراع
مشيرا الى ان العنف يمكن ان يغرق ملايين
الاشخاص في الجوع
اكد مبعوث الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
الى السودان على التزام المنظمه اتجاه
الشعب السوداني الذي يمر بظروف صعبه حيث
اكد ان المجتمع الدولي والمتطوعين
المحليين يبذلون قصار جهدهم للمساعده في
تحسين الظروف التي يمر بها السودانيون
مشاهدينا يا خرطوم بحري يعود الينا الصحفي
محمد اسحاق عثمان اهلا بكم محمد من جديد
وبدايه
نتحدث عن خدمات الكهرباء والماء والانترنت
والتي عانت بحر طويلا من انقطاعها منذ
بدايه هذه الازمه هل ما زال وضع على حاله
ام تحسنت جزئيا
نعم مرحبا من جديد احمد هذه واحده من
الاشكاليات التي يعاني منها المواطن
بالتحديد في منطقه بحري كما هو معلوم ولكن
الجديد في الامر بان بعض
الخدمه باعاده بدات تعود لبعض الاحياء هنا
في منطقه الخرطوم بحري اقصد خدمه المياه
كلها في نشرات سابقه بان بعد ان تواصلنا
مع السيد والي ولايه الخرطوم الذي اوضح
بان هناك
اثيار تنزل للميدان لمتابعه واصلاح العضبه
الذي اصاب هذه المحطات معلوم بان محطات
بحري احمد من المحطات الكبيره ولكن عانت
في الامن الاخيره من كثير من الاشكالات
والان بدا الفريق بحسب ما علمنا فريق
الصيانه بدا في اصلاح بعض الاعطاب كذلك
هناك مشكله في الكهرباء بدات ايضا
اصلاحها اللي هي بالتحديد في مناطق شمبات
التي تعثرت من القصه الاخيره الذي تعرضت
له هذه المنطقه او هذا الحي حي حي ولكن
احمد الجدير بالذكر بان واضح بان الجيش
بدا يتخذ تكتيكا او تكنيكا جديدا هذه
المره للمسارعه في حجم هذه المعركه
باستخدام
هذه الطائرات التي الاحظ بانها في زياده
وهي تحلق في تبع الخرطوم وانا احدثك في
هذه اللح
ظه في الاونه الاخيره بان الجيش اعتمد على
سلاح الطيران بصوره واضحه وعلى سلاح
المشاه على الارض فيما يلي مساله التنشيط
ان هذه الضربات التي يقوم بها الجيش هي
بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع تعتبر واحده
من الاشكاليات لانها تسبب خسائر كبيره جدا
في الارواح والممتلكات شكرا لكم بحري كنت
معنا الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان والان
مشاهدينا لم يخرطوم ينضموا الينا الكاتب
الصحفي ماهر ابو الجوخ اهلا بك استاذ ماهر
معنا هل من الدقه بمكان ان توصف هذه
الازمه بانها الاسوا في تاريخ السودان منذ
استقلاله وهل كل ما يحدث الان كان متوقعا
بالنسبه لما سبق من معطيات ومؤشرات في
الساحه السياسيه السودانيه
المشاهدين
هذه هي الازمه الاسوء لان تاريخيه في
السودان منذ العام 1955 ظلت كل المواجهات
خارج العاصمه في جنوب السودان او في جبال
النوبه او في النيل ادق السلطان او في
دارفور حتى المحدوده التي تعرض لها
العاصمه لمواجهات كانت مواجهات محدوده
للمره الاولى كانت في يوليو 76 والمره
الثانيه كانت في مايو 2008 كانت محاولات
من المحارب المعارضه لاسقاط النظام
بالهجوم على الخرطوم ولكن هذه المره لدينا
قوتين نظاميتين منتشرتان في الخرطوم
ومنتشرتان في الولايات هذه القوتين الان
بانه حينما يضرب راس الشعوب الثعبان يضربه
في راسه وبالتالي هو يقصد بانه يخوض
المعركه في الخرطوم ولذلك
عاد مرتبطه بالاختصاب لان اكثر من 80% من
المصانع واحد شركات الحاضله في مجالات
عديده سواء كانت الادويه او الصناعات
الغذائيه او المياه او حتى الوقود هي كلها
تحميات لديها تاثيرات اذا هذه الازمه
الحالي هي تمثل هي الازمه الازمه لانها
تدور في منطقه العاصمه الخرطوم وهي التي
تعتبر معقل النشاط السياسي والاعلامي
والتجاري والاقتصادي وحتى الخارجي في
التواصل مع العالم الخارجي
الاسوء نعم والتي تعتبر ايضا هنا خرطوم
تعتبر سودانا مصغرا شكرا لك كنت معنا من
الخرطوم الكاتب الصحفي ماهر ابو الجوخ
تحيته
[موسيقى]
نعمل بهذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم امكانيات
اللي ما موجوده هنا
بعض الادويه والمعدات
اكد مندوب السعوديه الدائم لدى منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي صالح السحباني ان
المملكه تبذل جهودا حديثا لحل الازمه
السودانيه وانهاء الصراع وطالب الصحي باني
الاطراف السودانيه بوقف كافه اشكال
التصعيد لافت الى مواصله القيام بدور
انساني ودبلوماسي كبير في الازمه كما
شددها على تطلع بلاده الى وقف دائم
للاقتتال في السودان وانخراط الاطراف في
حوار من اجل السلام هذا ودعا مندوب
السعوديه خلال اجتماع منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي الى احترام كافه البعثه
الدبلوماسيه بالسودان والعمل على حمايتها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات